aquí cinco cuerpos encontrados atados en
un sótano aquí una fosa común llena de
gente vestida de civil en lucha al norte
de kiev las autoridades ucranianas
presentaron a la prensa lo que denuncian
como crímenes de guerra rusas reportan
que 300 civiles han muerto aquí el
presidente ucraniano tras visitar la
zona se mostró preocupado todos
los ocupantes probablemente tratarán de
ocultar las huellas de sus crímenes no
lo hicieron en lucha cuando se retiraron
pero en otra zona es posible
en bus a kiev no tienen ninguna duda de
que rusia irresponsable y se apoyan
especialmente en estas imágenes
suministradas por satélites
estadounidenses y muestran los cuerpos
de los civiles en la carretera desde
mediados de marzo
el kremlin afirma que los cuerpos fueron
arrojados tras la retirada del ejército
ruso siguen denunciando una puesta en
escena
mientras que las fuerzas rusas
abandonado en la zona de butch halla el
30 de marzo como parte de una crisis
durante los tres días siguientes el
alcalde habló en televisión diciendo que
la ciudad estaba volviendo a la vida
normal las fuerzas ucranianas también
aparecieron allí se mostraron calles
donde no había cuerpos de seguridad no
pocos woods las autoridades rusas dicen
que documentarán lo que llaman la
verdadera naturaleza de los
acontecimientos en mucha moscú tiene
previsto presentar el martes ante el
consejo de seguridad de la onu pruebas
de su no implicación